he used to be Sam bankman freed and now
he is Sam bankman jailed a Manhattan
Jury has found Sam bankman freed guilty
of two counts of wire fraud and five
conspiracy crimes the verdict came at
the eve of trial where bankman free
testified that he knew nothing about
crypto that he was too busy and lazy to
get haircuts and he thinks of himself as
a smart guy in many ways uh but not
always and uh that he could not recall
making dozens of statements that he
actually did make on video or audio now
company Executives Caroline Ellison Gary
Wang and nishad Singh pleaded guilty and
testified against him bankman freed and
his three co-conspirators have come a
long way since their shared frat house
in the Bahamas bankman freed is facing
decades in prison and the government
isn't even done with him yet so today
we're going to talk about what happened
at the trial of Sam bankman freed now as
you probably know FTX was a crypto
exchange founded by Sam bakman freed and
Friends FTX customers deposited money at
FTX believing that the company was
following basic risk management
practices however FTX secretly loaned
billions in customer money to its
Affiliated crypto trading firm firm Alam
research which was led by Caroline
Ellison Alam did not post collateral for
those loans from FTX and when the bottom
dropped out of the crypto Market in 2022
Alama lost a lot of money that belonged
to FDX customers those customers weren't
able to get their money back out and FTX
and its principles lied to customers
about the entire scheme creating fake
spreadsheets backdating staking fees and
withdrawing massive amounts of cash to
fund their luxurious Lifestyles and as I
explained in the last video about FTX
the company's implosion led to Swift
action by three federal agencies and the
United States attorney's office for the
southern district of New York indicted
bankman freed for wire fraud and
conspiracy to commit wire fraud against
FTX customers wire fraud and conspiracy
to commit wire fraud against Alam
research lenders conspiracy to commit
Securities fraud against FTX investors
conspiracy to commit Commodities and
fraud against FDX customers and
conspiracy to commit money laundering
now bankman Freed's friends and
co-executive took plead deals to testify
against him Gary Wang a co-founder of
FTX pleaded guilty to four counts of
wire fraud and conspiracy to commit wire
fraud Commodities fraud and securities
fraud NAD Singh the former director of
engineering pleaded guilty to six
conspiracy charges and Caroline Ellison
pleaded guilty to seven counts of Fraud
and conspiracy and is facing about 50
years in prison but has a cooperation
agreement that could lead to her serving
far less time or none at all
additionally the Securities Exchange
Commission or SEC charged SPF Ellison
and other Executives with violations of
the Securities act and of the exchange
act now the Commodities Futures Trading
commission also filed fraud charges
against the group and those cases are
still pending and believe it or not that
was just the beginning of the bad news
for bankman freed the government filed a
superseding indictment in March of 2023
which charged him with multiple counts
of foreign bribery conspiracy and bank
fraud that were scheduled for a separate
trial due to start in March of 2024 now
obviously Sam Bank MRE is going to need
a good lawyer for his appeal but if you
want a great lawyer my firm the eagle
team can help if you've been in a car
crash suffered a data breach or have a
workers's comp issue or Social Security
Disability we can represent you or help
find you the right attorney who can
because it's so important to talk to a
lawyer right away so you can get the
best representation so just click on the
link in the description for a free
consultation with my team because you
just need a legal team you need the
eagle team the link is down below and as
you may recall bankman freed was
initially under house arrest at his
parents home after posting a $250
million Bond but then he got caught
asking the general counsel of an FDX
affiliate to have a constructive
relationship and vet things with each
other the lawyer was known as witness
number one in the indictment uh so that
was a really bad idea next bankman freed
leaked portions of Caroline Ellison's
private diary to a New York Times
Reporter which prosecuted said was an
attempt to intimidate her judge Kaplan
said the bankman freed tried to cover
his tracks by meeting the reporter in
person at his parents home and
consequently he was remanded to jail at
bankman Fred's New York trial
prosecutors alleged that he
misappropriated and embezzled billions
of dollars which he spent on expensive
real estate private jets political
contributions and celebrity endorsements
according to prosecutors bankman freed
was The Mastermind behind FDX and its
related entities he gave customers
investors and media the false impression
that customer funds deposited with FTX
were safe and that there was a firewall
between FTX and alamaa research uh
Witnesses said that bankman freed was
fully aware of the relationship between
the two companies and that he knowingly
allowed customers to deposit their money
into bank accounts that actually
belonged to Alam former FTX Chief
technology Officer Gary Wang testified
that bankman free directed him to
implement changes in fx's computer code
that would give Alam special privileges
such as a $65 billion line of credit and
an exemption from being automatically
liquidated should his positions lose
value this enabled the theft of the
funds of course the star witness for the
prosecution was Caroline Ellison who is
also bankman Freed's ex-girlfriend she
claimed that bankman freed told her to
make up fake balance sheets when one of
alam's lenders wanted financial
information Ellison asked bankman freed
what to do at this point it was 2022
crypto was crashing and Alam had
secretly borrowed $10 billion from fx's
customers and loaned 5 million back to
FTX entities of course these
transactions had been concealed from
lenders and customers and bankman freed
needed them to stay that way Ellison
testified that bankman freed told her to
prepare seven alternative balance sheets
Ellison testified quote he suggested I
should prepare some alternative ways of
presenting the information and send it
to him I understood him to be directing
me to come up with ways to conceal
things in our balance sheet we both
agreed would look bad bankman free told
her to send the lender balance sheet
number seven which didn't disclose money
taken from FDX customers the balance
sheet made it look as if Alama had
around $10 billion in liabilities rather
than the 15 billion looking at the
spreadsheets it should come as no
surprise that Ellison agreed to flip on
bankman freed not surprisingly the only
way to get a huge reduction in her
sentence was to cooperate with
prosecutors and so Ellison testified for
13 hours against bankman freed Ellison
told the jury that bankman freed asked
her to break the law uh the prosecutor
asked when you were working in Alama did
you commit any crimes and she replied
yes we did of course the biggest crime
they committed was using FTX customer
funds to make loan repayments for alamaa
research and Ellison described this as
Sam's decision she said he repeatedly
directed her to quote use FTX customer
funds to repay our loans Gary Wang and
NAD Singh gave similar testimony so
prosecutors argue that bankman freed was
The Mastermind behind A10 billion fraud
he claimed he didn't realize that the
customer funds were used illegally until
right before the company collapsed in
November of 2022 of course here he is in
December of 2022 saying he had no idea
things were breaking bad I didn't ever
uh try to commit fraud on anyone I I was
excited about the prospects of FTX a
month ago so his defense had two main
themes first that he might have made
mistakes but he was such a super nerd
that he didn't know any better uh the
crypto Market was volatile and new and
they were making so much money it was
hard to even keep track of it he argued
he was detached from day-to-day
decisions and his subordinates were to
blame and the second thing was that
Ellison was the power behind the throne
she was the one who made the careless
decisions leaving bankman freed to clean
up her mess for that defense to work
bankman Freed's lawyer Mark Cohen would
have to hurt Ellison on
cross-examination but the cross-
examination was by all accounts a
disaster other reports that the lawyer
repeatedly changed topics change dates
of discussion often seemingly at random
and he failed to knock holes in her
testimony making judge Kaplan so quote
puzzled and impatient that he repeatedly
ask Cohen where he was going with his
questions or what exactly he was talking
about which yeah is not in ideal
cross-examination and Ellison's
testimony destroyed both of bankman
Freed's narratives bankman freed and
Ellison were not only keeping track of
all that cash they were inventing new
balance sheets to conceal their fraud
and of course the company did keep one
balance sheet that appears to be real
you can see it here where it's labeled
main the main balance sheet contains the
real numbers that only FTX and alamaa
were allowed to see and the other tabs
show the alternative spreadsheets
although the details of this case are
complicated the prosecutors had a pretty
clean argument to make to the jury these
people knew the numbers and lied about
them in order to deliberately mislead
lenders and customers balance sheet
number seven deleted some things to make
it look like the company was more liquid
uh and less leveraged and that is you
know fraud and prosecutors played a
recording of the All Hands meeting that
Ellison held in November of 2022 when
they were trying to sell FTX to save
elated FTX from bankruptcy and an
employee actually asked Ellison whether
the decision to borrow FTX customer
funds was a YOLO decision and Elison
said no it was done over a period of
years and this countered bankman Freed's
narrative that everything just got
frantic at the end in of the waiting
months of 2022 and speaking of YOLO
bankman free testified in his own
defense now this is always a gamble uh
but it's especially risky in a case
where the person on trial has given so
many public interviews after his arrest
which is something the prosecutors
exploited on cross-examination but you
know when things are going very very
poorly sometimes you have to take a Hail
Mary but bankman Freed's testimony on
Direct was that he wasn't aware of
everything that was happening and by the
time it imploded he was frantically
trying to understand what was going on
he appointed Ellison as CEO of Alama in
2021 and then stepped away from his
involvement in Alama research according
to him but on November 7th 20122 as
customers demanded their money back he
tweeted FDX is fine assets are fine and
this was portrayed as another attempt to
mislead customers so prosecutors argued
that bankman freed used Alam and FTX as
a slush fund that he could use for
personal loans and Investments bankman
freed denied that his story was that
most of FDX users opted into spot margin
trading which is a risky system that
allows for highly leverag cryptos
currency trades significant losses were
an inherent risk of spot margin trading
especially uh if other risk management
standards weren't followed and bankman
freed contended that alamaa was just
another Trader on the spot margin system
and that the crypto market crash created
a perfect storm that drained customer
accounts but as prosecutors demonstrated
Alam wasn't just another Trader who was
treated like everybody else and bankman
fre admitted that Alam was a Trader a
stable coin converter and a liquidity
provider he argued that there was
nothing wrong with Alam playing multiple
roles but as the prosecutor pointed out
bankman free personally own 90% of alam
plus a big stake in FTX he was making
money through every one of alam's
functions and bankman freed used Alam to
launch FTX and before FTX had its own
bank accounts bankman freed wired
customer deposits into an account owned
by alamaa because it had an easier time
opening accounts with banks and most of
ftxs users were individuals but alama's
main sub account had a $65 billion line
of credit which effectively allowed the
crypto hedge fund to borrow unlimited
amounts of money so he wasn't alarmed by
the fact that alamaa consistently had a
negative balance of $2 billion in 2021
uh bankman freed argued that the company
had other assets outside of FTX but the
same was not true for all of the other
FTX users who did not have an unlimited
credit line uh the prosecutor pointed
out that alam's largest account wasn't
even involved in the spot margin trading
program meaning that its losses
shouldn't have impacted other accounts
at all and regarding that special code
that Gary Wang claimed bakman free told
him to put into the code of FTX B free
testified that he asked Wang and Singh
to prevent Alama from accidentally being
liquidated but didn't know that this
code actually enabled Al to carry out a
negative balance and prosecutors argued
that bankman free deliberately portrayed
himself as a kind of pinball wizard for
the crypto crowd with his cargo shorts
Wild Hair in habit of playing video
games during meetings Ellison said that
this was a ruse designed to prye money
from investors who liked the idea of an
eccentric genius Ellison said that he
had said that he thought his hair had
been very valuable and he had gotten big
bonuses at Jane streak because of his
hair the prosecutor asked him to verify
a quote reported by the New York Times
where he said quote I honestly think
it's Nega negative EV estimated value
for me to cut my hair I think it's
important for people to think I look
crazy so the US attorney tried to show
the jury that bankman freed had two
different stories about his role in Alam
in FTX before the crash he claimed that
FDX used solid risk management protocols
and that he was involved in every aspect
of the business and after FDX and alamaa
collapsed he claimed that he was just an
innocent bystander who acted in good
faith but was in over his head and
couldn't control what other Executives
did the prosecutors confronted him with
dozens of statements he made on the
record to various media outlets and
bankman freed repeatedly said that he
did not recall making those statements
and by the end of his testimony he
answered I do not recall more than 100
times on the witness stand even when
being confronted with actual video and
audio tape and former FTX Executives
testified that he ordered them to spend
customer money on real estate and other
fun stuff bankman freed repeatedly said
that he didn't remember giving those
instructions and the jury obviously
didn't believe bankman freed had a
memory problem so the jury convicted
bankman freed on all seven counts of the
indictment uh it was a complicated case
but the jury only needed a few hours to
reach an unanimous verdict you might
have noticed that bankman Freed's
conviction happened uh less than one
year after the company's filed for
bankruptcy on November 11th 2022 which
is lightning speed for a white collar
trial in comparison it took more than
three and a half years to bring
Elizabeth Holmes to trial now the
statutory maximum sentence is around 115
years but as legal eagle viewers know uh
the the federal sentencing guidelines
will determine his sentence not anywhere
near the maximum you can watch scal
break down the factors the guidelines
take into consideration but the main
factors are the SC of the crimes and the
amounts stolen and the criminal history
of the defendant now bankman free
doesn't have criminal history but the
sheer scale of the fraud was obviously
huge and he lied and tried to cover
everything up so realistically judge
Kaplan could sentence him to 15 to 25
years in prison plus restitution judges
retain discretion to consider the impact
of White Collar fraud on the victims
Elizabeth Holmes was sentenced to 11
years whereas Bernie maof got 150e
sentence and although Holmes ripped off
investors she also scammed people who
thought they were getting legitimate
tests done made offs victims on the
other hand included numerous small
investors sentencing is scheduled for
March of 2024 which is right before the
next trial is expected to begin so while
SF is going to jail for the foreseeable
future there's still a lot out there on
the internet that can hurt you which is
where today's sponsor nordvpn comes in
because you know incognito mode isn't
actually Incognito right because with
nord's no logs policy your internet
service provider doesn't get to Snoop on
what you're searching and neither does
Nord VPN now I especially like to use
Nord while on traveling and using
unfamiliar networks which we all tend to
do this time of year and Nord is more
than just a VPN because it comes with a
whole Suite of threat protection tools
for example if you follow some of your
favorite graders on social media you
might have heard the stories of a
channel getting hacked basically a
Creator losing access to a successful
attack or a leaked password in fact
Alex's Corner one of our nebula friends
recently got their Channel stolen and
turned into a repository for
cryptocurrency scam videos but nordvpn's
threat protection include specific
features to warn you about fishing links
as well as features like a blocker for
malicious ads and dark web monitoring to
alert you if your passwords have been
leaked and of course nordvpn is a great
VPN with Nord you can surf the web
anonymously and your location stays
private it allows me to set my location
all over the world which lets me access
different versions of my favorite
websites and when I'm out of the country
and I try to connect with my Gmail and a
bunch of other things that I'm logged
into all those accounts usually would
just freak out and tell me that I'm
being hacked so now I just reroute my
connection to the US and my Gmail and
everything else is perfectly happy and
not only is nor the fastest VPN on the
planet but you get 24/7 customer support
to help you whenever you need it and a
30-day money back guarantee for all
users so give nordvpn a try by clicking
the link that's on screen right now or
down in the description every purchase
of the 2-year plan will receive four
bonus months on top and that's
completely risk-free with nord's 30-day
money back guarantee so click on the
link below to get up to four months free
with a huge discount uh and a free
30-day moneyb guantee with nordvpn after
that click on this link over here for
more legal eagle or I'll see you in
court